[Music]
EU commissioner for international
partnerships ambassadors secretary
general distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen it is an honor for me to take
the floor this morning I put Impe on
behalf of the European Union soon after
taking up my post as European
Commissioner for international
partnerships
let me first warmly thank Kenya and
president Kenyatta for hosting this
summit in the times we live this summit
itself is a strong proof together we
stand against the tide of breaking ties
by beginning with the fundaments I
believe that I proceeds we only in the
dictionary European Union strongly
promotes cooperation dialogue mutual
respect and joint push for better in we
there is the power to change the world
to reflect the same the large number of
heads of state and government who have
made a trip to Nairobi from Africa the
Caribbean and the Pacific is proof of
the active role that Africa plays in
promoting multilateralism
and south-south cooperation we at the EU
share this objective multilateralism is
key for us all with this in mind this
ACP summit on a transformed ACP
committed to multilateralism is the
perfect place for the European Union to
convey our message of support in earnest
because the partnership that Pines the
African Caribbean and Pacific group of
states and the European Union together
is truly special our partnership is both
long-lasting and unique it is the only
one that spans the globe from north to
south and east to west our challenge
will be to make this partnership deliver
the best possible results not only
bilaterally but as a week or four
multilateralism as well we are now at
Crossroads but across roads in the
positive sense because we have an
opportunity to decide on the best way
forward together allow me to take a look
back at the path we have taken to get us
here because I think we can be proud we
have shown the world that we can join
forces to bring about real change on
issues of global importance let me just
tell you two concrete steps we came
together around the sustainable
development goals and we formed a high
ambition coalition to get the Paris
climate agreement through these are
major achievements
and we must build on them our
multi-dimensional partnership has proven
time and again that we are stronger when
we stand together together we are a
hundred and seven countries representing
more than a billion and a half people
together we account for more than half
of the seats at the United Nations we
can build a powerful alliance that
reflects our common interests and values
in the International agenda together we
are forced to be a reconnect with so
while some are questioning the future of
multilateralism we are showing the world
that multilateralism is very much alive
acting together is how we can give our
Lions more weight on the clock world
state and make a real difference to
tackle of global challenges this starts
with implementing the Paris agreement
and achieving the Sustainable
Development Goals which bring brings me
to the future in our view the agreement
we adopt to succeed Cotonou must serve
four basic purposes firstly as a
blueprint for our future partnership it
must be able to cope with the trends and
realities of our modern world a lot has
changed in the 20 years since the cotton
agreement was adopted secondly our
agreement must be an example of the new
development paradigm we are in we are in
this together
the SDG framework and the Paris
agreement must be at the core of our
work and our partnership
thirdly the new agreement must be
flexible that is why we believe in one
common foundation of values and
principles this one foundation should be
complemented by three regional
partnerships and these partnerships
should be action-oriented and portly the
agreement must be fair because partners
treat each other fairly with the
agreement in place I know that our
partnership will go from strength to
strength we should then focus on
priority areas the 2030 agenda for
sustainable development including Eric
eradicating poverty fighting climate
change protecting biodiversity
supporting ocean governance and
sustainable investment these are core
themes of your summit and core themes of
our partnership they rest on
multilateralism they are areas where we
can make a difference for the better the
2030 agenda is our common plan of action
for people the planet and prosperity we
need to act now and we need to act
together let me give you an an example
none of us can hide from climate change
this is something that our partners in
the Caribbean and the Pacific know only
too well weather hazards are becoming
even more frequent and server for some
rising sea levels are putting their very
existence at risk very recently right
here in Kenya problems have taken a
tragic turn
after several chart unusually heavy
rains have affected over 300,000 people
18,000 people have been
placed and at least 120 people have died
due to fluids and landslides the
European Union sends its condolences but
I'm afraid that condolences are not
enough we cannot simply stand by and let
strategies strike we need to act now and
I am a bigger and big believer in the
power of youth you must all have heard
of great at Turnberry how she is
rallying her generation and how she's
demanding all of us to act in Europe
politicians are already acting the
president of the European Commission or
Suliban de Lyon is working hard to bring
a European Korean deal into being
we aim to lead the climate right from
the front our level of ambition is high
this is only right given the scale of
the problems we face but we need more
than European a clean deal because we
can not win the fight alone and that's
why our partnership with all of you is
crucial to make this planet secure and
sustainable for generations to come
therefore the Green Deal is a truly a
joint opportunity on critical issues our
partnership must set the agenda and
through our joint action on a positive
agenda we will be able to learn from
each other as true partners ladies and
gentlemen the kind of future for us as
partners reminds me very much of the
African philosophy of Ubuntu I am
because we are we would do well to make
that abiding principle
in Finnish we said we have a saying a
strong will takes you through the praise
stone the equivalent in English would be
where there is a will there is a way the
will is there and the way your head
beyond the crossroads is becoming ever
clearer it will take us forwards a prior
to future for us all for a vibrant a CPU
partnership of shared values is not only
good for us it is good the whole world
thank you I thank you your excellency I
am here to convene you that the new
european union leadership attaches major
importance to the european union's
relationship with Kenya this partnership
will be driven by the five pillars of
the European Union's new geopolitical
commission addressed to me by president
von der Leyen
Creon deals digital and data data
technologies alliances for sustainable
growth and jobs migration partnerships
and governance peace and security so in
this period I have been particularly
pleased to take part in the signing of
this important finance contract between
the European Investment Bank and the
Eastern and South and African Trade and
Development Bank this signing ceremony
is not only of the good relationship
between the European Commission and
European Investment Bank
but also between the European Union's
institutions and international financing
partners with green deals being one of
the key pillars of the new geopolitical
commission
I would like to radiate my commitment to
climate action in close partnership with
the government of Kenya this financed
contract will be vital to our efforts to
support climate action and renewable
energy projects in particular it will
also improve access to long-term finance
for small and medium sized enterprises
in international and local currencies
thus contributing to chop creation and
addressing a root cause of migration so
this is a great honor and privilege to
be here thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Applause]